of course if you can simply use less
memory that's great but of course your
goal is to minimize the dynamic object
allocation and de-allocation freeing up
those dynamic objects is what the
garbage collector is cleaning up after
so you really want to try to minimize
dynamic object allocation one way to do
that of course is to manage your own
static object pools implement your own
memory management for example you can
allocate an array of objects and hang
onto that whole array and just swap out
which one's of those you're actually
using of course you need to be sure that
you're not actually allocating more than
you need but the key to reducing the
impact of garbage collection lies in
eliminating excessive object churn not
just memory size finally of course you
need to test your code very carefully
for memory leaks since memory is so
constrained it's doubly important that
you don't leak memory and you don't want
to keep increasing your static memory
pool there are whole books and
discussions on best practices to avoid
memory leaks so we won't go into this in
depth here